hi I'm now the Marco and I'm here to
read you're thirsty tweet you can just
tell now the Marco has a nice deck it's
in his eyes maybe what I died
please scatter my ashes on now the
Marcos chest hair I'm not sure if I want
that I mean I'd probably have to shower
like two or three times that night nyle
dimarco could use me as a hand puppet to
be honest I don't know what that means
do you know what that means like a hand
puppet Oh how do you sign I want to suck
your toes all right so here your toes I
want to suck up hey now the Marco if you
need someone to apply oil on your abs
for photoshoots let me know absolutely
I'll be putting out applications pretty
soon sound keep an eye out I hated
facial hair
until I saw Naldo Marco hmm that's an
honor thank you now DeMarco could punch
me in the throat and I'd be like oh damn
you right I don't need to breathe yeah
but I don't want to punch you I need all
of you alive on this earth mood now the
Marcos hairy thighs you know it's
getting pretty close to summer I might
just shave it all off when I say I want
nyle DiMarco to suffocate me to death
with his naked body I actually mean I
want now DeMarco to suffocate me with
his naked body come give me a hug
unless they're on nyle DiMarco I could
really care less about ABS I think a lot
of people have better abs than me but
thank you now the Marco could literally
shove his foot up my ass and I'd say
thank you I'm not sure what to say to
that but you're welcome
that's sure if I want to do that either
now the Marco could literally chokeslam
me into a pit of ass
like I said I need all of my fans alive
I don't want any of you to die thank you
so much for all your tweets I'm looking
forward to seeing more in the future
you're all talking crazy
[Music]